FIRST, A DOSE OF REALITY.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
ALL RIGHT.
TODAY MY FAVORITE SUBJECT CAME
UP AGAIN.
THE COVID-19 BRIEFING.
YOU KNOW, ARE THERE TREATMENTS
OUT THERE THAT ARE ALREADY IN
USE WITH MINIMAL SIDE EFFECTS
THAT COULD BRING RELIEF TO OUR
PEOPLE IN OUR ECONOMY?
OUR OWN JOHN ROBERTS PRESSED
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI ABOUT THE DRUG
THAT WE INTRODUCED TO THE WIDER
PUBLIC MONDAY.
>> DR. FAUCI, IT WAS EXPLAINED
YESTERDAY THERE HAS BEEN SOME
PROMISE WITH HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE,
THIS POTENTIAL THERAPY FOR
PEOPLE INFECTED WITH CORONAVIRUS
IS.
THERE ANY EVIDENCE TO SUGGEST AS
WITH MALARIA IT COULD BE USED
AGAINST CORONAVIRUS?
>> THE ANSWER IS NO.
THE EVIDENCE THAT YOU’RE TALKING
ABOUT, JOHN, IS ANECDOTAL
EVIDENCE.
AS THE COMMISSIONER OF THE FDA
AND THE PRESIDENT MENTIONED
YESTERDAY, WE’RE TRYING TO
STRIKE A BALANCE BETWEEN MAKING
SOMETHING WITH A POTENTIAL OF AN
EFFECT TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AVAILABLE.
AT THE SAME TIME THAT WE DO IT
UNDER THE AUSPICE OF A PROTOCOL
THAT WOULD GIVE US INFORMATION
TO DETERMINE IF IT’S TRULY SAVE
AND TRULY EFFECTIVE.
BUT THE INFORMATION THAT YOU’RE
REFERRING TO SPECIFICALLY IS
ANTIDOTE
ANTIDOTAL.
>> Laura: I HAVE GREAT RESPECT
FOR DR. FAUCI.
BUT WHEN YOU HEAR SOMETHING IS
ANECDOTAL ASIDE FROM THE
CLINICAL TERMINOLOGY, TO MOST
PEOPLE, IT DOESN’T SOUND HOPEFUL
OR IMPRESSIVE.
AND ANECDOTAL DOESN’T DESCRIBED
THE FINDINGS OF THE WORLD’S TOP
RESEARCHERS THAT JUST A FEW DAYS
AGO PUBLISHED RESULTS OF THEIR
FIRST STUDY ON
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE AND
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE WITH
ERYTHROMYCIN.
A LOT OF YOU HAVE TAKEN ZPACS
OVER THE YEARS.
CHECK OUT THEIR FINDINGS.
DESPITE THE SMALL SAMPLE SIZE,
OUR SURVEY SHOWS THAT
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE TREATMENT IS
SIGNIFICANTLY ASSOCIATED,
SIGNIFICANTLY, WITH VIRAL LOAD
REDUCTION OR DISAPPEARANCE IN
COVID-19 PATIENTS AND THE EFFECT
IS REINFORCED BY ERYTHROMYCIN.
NOW LOOK AT THE CHART.
THE BLUE LINE IS THE CONTROL
GROUP.
THEY TOOK NOTHING.
BAD FOR THEM.
THEY ALL HAVE THE VIRUS AFTER
SIX DAYS.
THE RED REPRESENTS THOSE THAT
RECEIVED HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
SO SOME IMPROVEMENT.
40% OR SO STILL HAD THE VIRUS.
LOOK AT THE YELLOW LINE.
THE YELLOW LINE REPRESENTS THE
PATIENTS AT THE END OF DAY FIVE
ONLY WHO ARE ON A PROTOCOL THAT
INCLUDED HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE AND
ERYTHROMYCIN.
NOW, THE RESEARCHERS IN THIS
STUDY AND THEY’RE ALL INCREDIBLY
PROMINENT EPIDEMIOLOGISTS AND
RESEARCHERS, DOZENS AND DOZENS.
THEY UNDERSTOOD WHEN THEY
UNDERSTOOD THE SEVERITY OF THE
GLOBAL CRISIS WE’RE FACING.
THEY ALSO UNDERSTOOD THE RISK TO
MILLIONS, MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
AROUND THE WORLD INCLUDING OUR
HEALTHCARE WORKERS.
AND THEY CONCLUDED AS A RESULT
OF ALL OF THIS THINKING AND WHAT
THEY LOOKED AT THE FOLLOWING.
WE THEREFORE RECOMMEND THAT
COVID-19 PATIENTS BE TREATED
WITH HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE AND
ERYTHROMYCIN TO CURE THEIR
INFECTION AND TO LIMIT THE
TRANSMISSION OF THE VIRUS TO
OTHER PEOPLE IN ORDER TO CURB
THE SPREAD OF COVID-19 IN THE
WORLD.
NOW, I UNDERSTAND THAT WE WANT
OUR OWN DATA THAT IS A LARGE
CONTROLLED STUDY.
I UNDERSTAND THAT IS NECESSARY.
AND THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
100% CORRECT.
AT THE SAME TIME RECOGNIZING THE
BENEFITS ALREADY REPORTED IN THE
USE OF THIS DRUG AND THE DRUG
COMBO THAT WE JUST MENTIONED.
BY THE WAY, HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE,
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON’T UNDERSTAND
THIS, BUT IT DOES NOT NEED TO BE
APPROVED BY THE FDA IN ORDER TO
BE ADMINISTERED BY DOCTORS FOR
OFF LABEL USE.
BECAUSE AS I SAID BEFORE, WE
DON’T HAVE TO GO OVER IT BUT
IT’S PRESCRIBED FOR ANTI-MALARIA
USE AND LUPUS IN SOME CASES.
OUR PHYSICIANS ARE ALREADY USING
IT IN OUR MAJOR HOSPITALS FOR
COVID PATIENTS.
THEY USED IT IN SOME CASES
AGAINST SARS WHICH HAD A HIGHER
MORTALITY RATE.
THE PRESIDENT, AS USUAL, HAS
SHARP INSTINCTS.
HE SEES THINGS THAT SOMETIMES
THE INTELLECTUALS AND ACADEMICS
MIGHT GET LOST IN THE DETAILS.
HE’S PUSHING TO GET MILLIONS OF
DOSES NOW INTO THE UNITED
STATES.
>> I’M A BIG FAN.
WE’LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
WE ALL UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
DOCTORS SAID IS 100% CORRECT.
IT’S EARLY.
YOU KNOW, I’VE SEEN THINGS THAT
ARE IMPRESSIVE.
WE’LL SEE IF IT’S EFFECTIVE.
IT’S A STRONG DRUG.
>> Laura: I CAN ALSO REPORT
TONIGHT THAT ANOTHER DRUG IS
ALSO SHOWING SIGNIFICANT PROMISE
IN THE FIGHT AGAINST COVID-19.
IT’S CALLED ECTEMRA.
IT’S AN ANTI LUKEN 6.
IT’S A ANTI-INFLAMMATORY
PRESCRIBED FOR RHEUMATOID
ARTHRITIS.
OFF LABEL USE IS BEING
IMPLEMENTED NOW BY THE CHINESE
WHO ARE FINDING THAT IT WORKS
VERY WELL AGAINST COVID-19.
ROESCH MAKES DIFFERENT VERSIONS
OF THIS DRUG.
OUR DOCTORS AND OUR HOSPITALS
NEED ALL THE AMMO THAT THEY CAN
GET TO FIGHT THIS DISEASE.
WE WANT FEWER PEOPLE TO NEED
VENTILATORS, RIGHT?
WE NEED TO REDUCE THAT ABSOLUTE
NECESSITY TO HAVE VENTS IN OUR
ICUs.
BECAUSE WE HAVE A CRITICAL
SHORTAGE.
WE HAVE TO GET PEOPLE HOME TO
QUARANTINE IF THEY’RE SICK.
THEN A NECESSARY AMOUNT OF TIME
TO GET THOSE PEOPLE HEALTHY AND
BACK TO WORK AS SOON AS THEY’RE
MEDICALLY CLEARED.
I RESPECT THE PROFESSIONALS
WORKING ON THIS AND WORKING
RIDICULOUS HOURS.
I RESPECT DR. FAUCI ENORMOUSLY.
IN AN IDEAL WORLD, WE WANT
EVERYTHING BUTTONED UP AS FAR AS
RANDOMIZED TRIALS GO BUT OUR
COUNTRY NEEDS HOPE RIGHT NOW.
A ALL THE BUREAUCRACIES HAVE TO